we've always had a Cabana - we've never
had it we don't have a banter not like a
good banter - gasps yeah yeah good
banter I'm telling you I'm telling you
that what you yelled at me in the
parking lot it's my mind calm down write
it down guys
bad pie said that no you yelled at me
what I smile at you for said you're
really talented and you should you need
to [ __ ] in
I forgot how you said it but you're just
kind of like you just taught me to step
it up your ass basically you're saying I
was being lazy and I loved it yeah and I
was I was I was I enjoyed what Chelsea
gave me yeah I enjoyed the work that I
did on the road like I do one thing I'm
not is lazing on the road cuz I still
hand out cards yeah and I know everyone
talks about that out here in LA still
that you know one thing I know about Jo
koy at the end of every set he handed
out postcards and to this day I still
never such a thing right now okay yeah
you did it the right way yeah all right
you amassed a fanbase a big one yeah and
you did the work on that I don't even go
outside to meet you know how you know
that I've seen it I know yeah and I feel
bad about it but people pick me up and
I'm small yeah they pick you up
yeah they pick me up on the neck no
you're funny you know hey you know I
made my point so as we try and pick you
up and you're heavy you're heavy
mm-hmm huh am i fat I'm just saying
they'll be real am i fat you're my same
height as my son I can throw my son
across the room by study or the same
exact height yeah because I'm 50 but I
can't throw my son in holder I mean I'm
old are you how old are you now 52 are
you really from no how about 47 right
where do you [ __ ] you 46 you're with the
same exact
we were but we're born on the same year
- yeah yeah Yanni shows you want to plug
nope are you really you go out every
week like that every week yeah yeah yeah
yeah you should - I always have fun I
watch you guys on this but I you know he
hates their I hate the wrong why you
should look at it as a bone it bro you
it you do it you're living your dream
and people in can't do it can't wait to
[ __ ] see Bobby I hate it because I
don't draw like you do yeah you do I
don't would you enjoy it more if he drew
if you drew like him
oh yeah could you be maybe making money
I don't make a lot of money on the road
I compared to these guys I don't and um
I'm not just somebody he'd you don't
travel like when you when he goes to on
when he goes on road gigs he just stays
in the hotel the whole time Bobby
probably you and your girlfriend
probably just that's no no no no no I
see your snaps I see historian
understand living number one can
generate he's more prolific than I am
into the generic generating material and
number two I just don't know sometimes I
just go maybe I don't want to do it I
don't know you know but I do it to make
pay my mortgage hmm but I don't I've
never like made a lot of compared to
these guys a lot of money yeah I I'm
telling you
yeah I mean when I was at Nordstrom Rack
and I would come see you remember and
you'd [ __ ] take me - yeah he's working
at North yeah [ __ ] I wasn't born
a Spanish media yeah we had part-time
jobs you have so you have somet work
that chant yeah cuz I had a [ __ ]
dream I was chasing goddamn post office
yeah I'm just saying one night like a
Friday night for you to shows yeah it's
probably two to three weeks of me going
on the right now that's 100% I mean we
have to talk about it I know how much
you make
all you do yeah because everyone knows I
I know the rule I know how much the pay
scales are yeah
I'm not saying I know how much you make
yeah I know I don't think you know what
but I do what I'm saying though is I
know I understand that but let me just
say this alright yeah yeah you know yes
you're not making yeah 95 percent of the
door like me yes yeah that's what I'm
saying and so you don't win sometimes
I'll go to a market and I know I don't
draw it hurts my feelings I go what am i
doing this works depressing and then you
make not that much money and then you
walk away and it's Department but those
people that came to see you [ __ ] love
you and they're gonna come back and
they're gonna tell your friends so you
just got to keep going back yeah but
every time we don't go back that's when
you lose your fans where when you yelled
at me in the car and said I was lazy
yeah yeah exactly yeah okay by the way
he yelled at me guys I don't want you
think I'm making this [ __ ] up
I do yeah yelled at me and I think he
was at CAA were you yelled at me at the
agency yeah I was in the parking lot
yeah in the car and that was the last
time I saw him how long ago was that
about three years ago yeah that's the
last time I saw him oh I've been seeing
him in three or [ __ ] years we've
texted
we've text yeah yeah but that was the
last time we talked and that was a
living okay he kind of threw that my
face but I'm telling you I kicked it
into overdrive after that man yeah but
[Music]